so let's go through the top seven
takeaways from Roy Moore's defeat in
Alabama what conservatives should really
learn number one no Roy Moore should not
have dropped out of this race after the
sexual impropriety allegations came out
they said there a lot of Republicans
saying now I should have dropped out
there should have been a write-in
candidate against Doug Jones we could
have run Luther stranger mo Brooks or
somebody not true totally ridiculous
let's look at the timeline on November
9th that is when the first allegations
against Roy Moore came out keep in mind
these are 40 year old allegations but on
November 9th
we learned that there is a woman who
says that when she was 14 Roy Moore was
sexually inappropriate with her he
sexually assaulted her and then a number
of other women came out and said oh yes
when I was 16 or 18 or 19 Roy Moore then
at the time 30 32 he got a little frisky
with me he too and it created this aura
of sexual harassment and sexual assault
those were the allegations these
allegations were conveniently timed you
notice you haven't heard about these
things for I don't know the 40 years
since they happened until just too late
for Roy Moore to get off that ballot so
people think it's very easy if Roy Moore
just dropped out then they put someone
else on the ballot in the Republican
would have won that isn't true
according to Alabama state code you can
only remove yourself from the ballot 676
days before the election so if it's
after that time period you can't get off
of the ballot if more had dropped out
his name would still be on that ballot
he still would have the Republican line
some people also don't know when you're
running for office you need to get a
number of lines so for instance when I
would run campaigns in New York we try
to pick up the Republican line the
conservative line the independence party
line they're always doing the Democrats
would get working families party but you
get those lines and then the more lines
you have the better your chances of
winning if were wrong or had dropped out
and the Republican establishment or
Donald Trump even had endorsed someone
like Luther Strange who had lost in the
primaries or mo Brooks who didn't really
have much of a shot even though those
candidates would have been more likely
to win the general they would have had
to be a write-in camp
so there's a very low chance that would
have happened I think Luther strangers
polling it like 2% or something in a
write-in campaign in general election
ROI more dropping out would have
guaranteed the seat would have gone to a
Democrat instead of what we saw which
was a tight race but you know two three
points separating these it was a clear
outcome basically but at least a close
race dropping I would have guaranteed it
to Democrats and I know what you're
gonna hear you're gonna hear well Lisa
Murkowski the senator from Alaska she
won a write-in campaign in 2010 it is
completely different she had a lot of
things going for her one she had
enormous support which Roy Moore lacked
she was an incumbent she already had the
seat she or he had universal name
recognition she came from a political
legacy family she was widely known as
the heir to a political family and she
had a political write-in campaign
campaign so her entire campaign was
about this right and she gave out
bracelets she instructed people on how
to spell her name it was just too late
there was a month till the election when
these allegations surfaced it couldn't
have happened added to all of this you
had Steve ban and inserting himself into
the Roy Moore campaign and playing it as
an anti establishment versus
establishment campaign so had Donald
Trump come out and endorsed the guy who
lost the Republican primary or someone
else it would have been seen widely as
opposing the will of voters opposing the
will of the populous and for a populist
president to do that it just can't
happen at the end of this election it
was a choice between Roy Moore and Doug
Jones anybody who's trying to tell you
otherwise is selling you a fantasy
number to know the outcome is not
stunning the mainstream media will tell
you it's stunning it's unbelievable to
hear them tell it not since the Battle
of Lepanto has an underdog overcome so
much to get a victory
NBC News reported it's a stunning
victory Politico reported on the Alabama
earthquake the Washington Post democracy
dies in darkness called it miraculous
they're suggesting no one could have
ever predicted this this is a blowout
victory hmm did anybody predict that Roy
Moore would lose the general let's cut
to the tape loser
we'll definitely win no you know what
I'm saying
Roy has a very good chance of not
winning in the general election it's all
about the general don't forget we don't
stop here you have an election coming up
the day this is over so this is over a
Tuesday on Wednesday morning the new
race begins you got to be a Democrat
Luthor's gonna win easily and Roy's
gonna have a hard time winning Oh Donald
Trump Donald Trump is the guy who
predicted this right the leader of Roy
Morris party the Republican president he
predicted that Roy Moore would have a
very hard time he likely wouldn't win
the general election the mainstream
media are conveniently ignoring this
today because they need this to seem
like a seismic shift they need this to
show that all of the Republican momentum
all of the Trump momentum conservative
policy legislation like we haven't seen
in our lifetimes is coming to an end
they have to show that it stops that
Donald Trump predicted it during the
primary he said yeah I don't know this
guy it's a tough it's gonna be a tough
race for him he isn't a great candidate
he's a flawed candidate this was before
any of the sexual allegations came out
just based on his appeal as a candidate
absent the dirty tricks absent people
coming out of the woodwork to accuse him
of things he knew it would be a tough
race this isn't stunning stop repeating
that number three Ronald Reagan's 11th
commandment now more than ever
Ronald Reagan was fine of saying there
is an 11th commandment we all must live
by thou shalt not speak ill of a fellow
Republican unfortunately many
Republicans were all too happy to jump
on the bandwagon against Roy Moore when
these accusations came out in part
perhaps because the going got a little
tough that's a that is a bad accusation
to say that a man in his 30s is creeping
on fourteen-year-old girls and so when
the going gets tough you want to run
away from that also I think people just
don't like more a lot of some
Republicans don't like him because of
his trump enos something they don't like
him because he's a bible-thumper
they don't like him because he seems a
little slick
little unctuous whatever do not speak
ill of a fellow Republican because by
the way their this sexual mania that
took over the last days of the Roy Moore
campaign they had one piece of solid
evidence they had one piece of solid
evidence Gloria Allred showed it off
with that one accuser during her big
press conference it was a yearbook that
purported to have a signature from Roy
Moore saying sweet things to the little
girl we now know it has been admitted
that that evidence was at least
partially fabricated and they hid that
it was fabricated when they showed it so
the only hard evidence we have is not
credible and yet Republicans were quick
to throw Roy Moore under the bus instead
of saying nothing at all instead of
spent stepping back a little bit and
saying well let's wait and see how this
plays out
I'm not totally sure because now there's
a precedent which is if you make
allegations sexual allegations in
particular against a Republican you will
be assumed guilty until proven innocent
not a good way for Republicans to move
forward it really damages us hopefully
we'll learn not to be so quick on the
trigger in the future
number four Republicans need better
opposition research this is the part
where I talk about how the allegations
were pretty strong so these allegations
sure they were 40 years old but we know
from Moore's autobiography that he has a
thing for young teenage girls we know
from Morris 2005 autobiography that he
met his current wife when she was a
teenager performing in a dance recital
he wrote quote I knew Kayla was going to
be a special person in my life and then
later when she was 23 I think they
connected and went on a date that's how
the story goes nevertheless he even
admitted that when she was a teenage
girl in a dance recital he had the eye
for her
so Roy Moore's opponents should have
known his Republican opponent should
have known this was a place ripe for
attack even if all of the allegations
were false they would be easy political
tricks to play they should have run
worse campaign should have protected
against that and Luther Strange's
campaign should have pounced on it if
these allegations are true they should
have found those people and they should
have made them make the claims during
the primaries so that strange would have
won and we would have a Republican
the Senate from Alabama if they if those
claims weren't true why more should have
protected against that it means that
Luther stranger's campaign was
incompetent I don't believe this was a
big conspiracy really by the
establishment I don't really buy that
Mitch McConnell knew about this and he
was sitting on it and hiding it I think
if they had been sitting on it they
would have played it in the primary they
don't want to lose that seat they could
have easily bumped out Roy Moore and
given it to Luther strange if this had
come out Republican voting was deeply
depressed in the general election they
easily could have defeated Roy Moore in
a primary and depressed his supporters
in that election but they didn't do it I
don't know if it's that we're lazy
because we've been running against the
Clintons who for whom every scandal of
the last three decades is common public
knowledge it's been plastered all over
TV for years and years and years but you
have to get better at opposition
research I place a lot of the blame for
this loss at Luther strangers feet and
at his campaign because they didn't
uncover this and more didn't protect
against it number five do not OD on Kofi
Kofi Fay is a hell of a drug folks
you've got to use it sparingly and
cautiously what I mean by that there is
a huge right-wing exuberance more than I
have ever seen in my entire life a young
life granted but you know I've been on
this earth a few decades at least and
we've never seen anything like this
wonderful conservative legislation
wonderful executive priorities wonderful
foreign policy good judges being
nominated courts being stacked we're
seeing massive tax reform that we
haven't seen since Reagan but there is a
limit there is a limit you can't go
crazy Donald Trump has completely shaken
up politics he's radically altered what
is acceptable
specifically in political speech in
campaign speech in what a candidate
looks like he's cracked this political
correct gross just the political
language where they say one thing and
really you know that they're lying but
they're lying in this way or they're
lying in that way
Donald trunk he cracked that he cracked
the political correctness he cracked the
credibility of the mainstream media but
you can't get away with everything
he hasn't abolished the rules of
politics entirely wrong or did not have
a way forward he did not know how to
pivot his campaign he gave this awful
interview with Sean Hannity let's hear
it you know miss Coffman do you know the
mother I don't know your scorp Minh from
anybody I know I've never talked to her
and ever had any contact with her
allegations of sexual misconduct with
her completely false I believe they're
politically motivated I believe they're
brought only to stop a very successful
campaign and that's what they're doing
I've never known this woman or anything
with regard to the other girls you
understand this was 40 years ago she
said that you asked her out on the first
of several dates but nothing progressed
beyond kissing I don't remember specific
dates not do not and I don't remember if
it was in that time or later but I do
not remember that but you know her but
you never dated her ever is that what
you're saying no her but I don't
remember going out on dates I knew her
as a friend if we did joint updates and
we did but I do not remember that that
is not an answer so he's talking about
two different girls there but he's
saying on the one that's never happened
this fourteen-year-old girl it never
happened
well did you date teenagers well no I
don't I don't remember specific dates
well did you date teenagers well you
know I that's not an answer if you're
gonna deny it deny it if you're gonna
own up to it own up to it and explain it
but move on pivot move on the way that
were tried to pivot was by blaming gays
and lesbians and the cultural left for
harping on this sure the cultural Left
might be harping on this you're not
going to be able to push your campaign
forward by trying to scapegoat gays and
lesbians when your own sexual behavior
is being called into question you have
to move forward wrong or didn't do that
he didn't have a clear enough vision for
his campaign and he didn't have the
courage or the strength or the political
smarts to address the issue and move
straight forward plow right by it
this brings us to number six never
defend never explain always attack this
is also from Ronald
and Ronald Reagan would say if you were
explaining you're losing but Roy Moore
just kept on explaining he kept on
saying well I never did this 40 years
ago and even when I did I got the
mother's permission that doesn't work
pal when you do that you you end up
looking like Frank from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia I am NOT gonna dilly your
kids I'm not like that we got to
definitely write a song about how we do
not diddle kids do not diddle kids it's
no good diddling kids there is no
quicker way for people to think that you
are diddling kids then by writing a song
about it you gotta write songs it says
oh I wouldn't do it with anybody that
could be a documentary of remorse
campaign that is what it looked like
when he came out and ready to explain
all of this
don't do that eventually he wised up and
then just denied it he called into
question some of the clearly the
fabrication on the yearbook signature
but that's what he looked like for weeks
when these allegations came out not a
good look there's no way to convince
somebody that you're not doing that when
you're constantly harping on these
things and going back and changing your
story slightly when Republicans were
confronted with various and sundry
allegations against Moore they would say
if you even support more you are a
pedophile there is a two-word answer
that they should have given Bob Menendez
Bob Menendez there is a sitting Democrat
United States Senator who federal
prosecutors think might have had sex
with underage prostitutes you don't hear
a peep about that you don't hear
Democrats calling on him to step down or
to resign the mainstream media have
blocked it out entirely because it
doesn't help out their narrative against
Republicans and against Roy Moore but
that's what they said the Democrats said
well if you vote for more you are a
pedophile and just to be precise about
language here what Roy Moore is accused
of is not pedophilia yet the old Greek
word for this is if Heba philia he's
accused of doing things weird sex stuff
with teenagers young teenage girls but
not with children there's a difference
between a six year old and a 16 year old
for instance I guess you could make that
point to them but the real attack you
have to make is pushing forward pushing
it back on them say not only are your
claims not true not only is your
evidence of the yearbook which was
fabricated not even is that not credible
but your own guy is sitting in the
United States Senate accused of having
sex with underage prostitutes Senator
Bob Menendez and you're saying nothing
on that and until Democrats answer for
that they have no credibility on this
issue and you don't owe them one single
explanation beyond that political votes
are when I vote for somebody I do not
suddenly take on all of their moral
characteristics that's not how it works
we live in reality and in reality we
have to elect people to represent us on
political issues in legislative bodies I
do not become Chuck Schumer because
Chuck Schumer represents the state of
New York I do not become Kamala Harris
because Kamala Harris represents
California
I don't even become Donald Trump because
I voted for Donald Trump in the
presidential election I had I don't have
billions of dollars I don't have the
kind of crazy hair none that doesn't
happen because there are steps between
the representatives and their
constituents don't buy into that lie and
hammer them hammer them hammer them have
I made myself clear I hope so next and
final point do not get hypnotized this
one's really hard because the the
mainstream media will do this to you
according to a report out from the media
Research Center today 91 percent of
evening news coverage about Donald Trump
is negative 91 percent this is way
higher than previous presidents
Republican or Democrat there is
wall-to-wall coverage of all of the sex
stuff with Roy Moore and what's the
refrain Roy Moore is a pedophile Roy
Moore is a pedophile doesn't really
analyze the evidence it doesn't analyze
what those words mean it doesn't analyze
what the accusations or how many decades
ago they took place but do not be
hypnotized I know you haven't seen
anything about Bob Menendez I know all
you've heard of that is what a mean
terrible rotten guy Roy Moore is but the
mainstream media or the communications
wing of the
kradic party do not believe what they're
saying there have been absurd
retractions in just the last few days
from CNN Washington Post The New York
Times they got stories completely wrong
important stories important stories
about so called collusion about the
White House about Donald Trump don't buy
what they are selling and don't buy
their premises because then you'll have
to arrive at their conclusions that
isn't true